galadriel pulled out her lightsaber and
said wakanda forever
set shivers up my spot token could have
never written anything better
nope true that bro
i wonder how the people at amazon must
be feeling the most expensive show in
television history has now become one of
the biggest underdogs i love it isn't
that that
should be i love it big corporate
underdog
what is going on there citizens of the
reject nation greg here hey john has
gone uh an apprehensive
fascinating emotion to lead with today
anyway guys we got ourselves uh i
believe the final trailer for the lord
of the rings the rings of power before
this premieres if you can go ahead leave
a like but i want to mention the amazon
trailer department they like giving us
them copyright claims so with that we
have someone help support the channel
enjoy this word from our sponsor i want
to say thank you to atlas vpn for
partnering up with us for sponsoring
this video i'm genuinely excited to be
working with the vpn because here at the
real rejects we believe in the power of
the vpn
security because we have had scares
ourselves and a vpn has really come in
handy so as much as you've probably
heard people shout out vpns over the
years they really are in my mind a
necessity so right now we are working
with atlas vpn and as i'm sure you guys
have heard before what does a vpn help
do helps keep your data safe helps keep
your information private from leaks and
hackers i remember one time that was
probably the first day we got a vpn and
we we had fun with accessing geo blocked
content from certain subscriptions and
i'm telling you it's a lot of fun it is
so this is something that i was really
jazzed to hear about because when i read
this i had to question and go is that
there's a real conversation that john
and i had this but this isn't like some
talking point i'm reading off of here
they have a really great deal right now
one of the best deals you can have for a
three-year subscription for just 199 a
month that's 82 off the normal price
along with a 30-day money-back guarantee
and there's other benefits that this
atlas vpn comes with you want to list
some of them john absolutely not only do
you get the basic protections but atlas
operates at super fast uninterrupted
speeds especially for things like 4k you
also have 24-hour support seven days a
week for all your customer service needs
and they can even help you find
discounts on online shopping as well as
subscriptions things like that again
it's all available in this deal that
won't be around long it's 1.99 a month
when you sign up for a three-year
subscription it applies to all the
devices in your home network sync them
all together protect anything and
everything you have connected to the
internet if you want to take advantage
of this go on down to the description
box hit our special link it helps the
channel definitely helps you and uh yeah
we very much appreciate atlas for uh
partnering up with us today yeah take
vpn seriously guys they really help
my brother gave his life hunting the
enemy
his task is now mine
[Music]
stand with me
ours was the work of something greater
[Music]
each of us
everyone
must decide who
we shall be
i am not the hero you seek
whatever it was you did potions below be
free of it
literal music could be your kingdom
lady dwarf
she's not the path of
fear that of faith
one thing we can do
better than any creature in all middle
earth
stay true to each other
even bigger in our feet
a little cheesy but i had nipple chills
right now
i can
why do you keep fighting
there's a tempest in me
you have fought long enough galatria put
up your sword
damn
without it what am i to be
sweet digs
very cool
very cool
i like it
i like it oh there's fighting words i
kind of prefer the uh the trailer that
came to the one that came out of comic
con i thought the the one prior really
captured a certain kind of tone that was
more appealing to me i'm not 100 sold on
the show just yet it just looks so gosh
damn beautiful to behold i imagine that
there's a
bit of that like fantasy romanticism to
its emotion i'm just a sucker for it i
am like even here i was like watching it
with this trailer song is just a funny
pick to me
um but you know like all those themes
about heroism and faith and believing in
yourself and going against the odds like
everything about the thematically was
seeming as about as cliche as you'd
expect
from such an epic fantasy adventure like
this but i'd be totally lying to you if
i said this this didn't look like such a
grand adventure of a time the one thing
that's popping up into my head from the
limited knowledge this guy has about
lord of the rings obviously we've seen
all the movies i believe you've read the
hobbit
yes you have and i've read the lord of
the rings in either page or audio form
combined what then break it down
it's not this
this is the drawing from like the
salmarillian and stuff which isn't even
like narrative stories so much as they
are just written histories in fact i
have a copy and i would like to read it
but it's one of those things where
people have been like look you should
know before you go in you're not in
store for the same kind of like epic
storytelling style that a lord of the
rings story is it looks like they're
trying to no that's exactly the point is
they're taking at least you know parts
of that history and then they're you
know building the novel and the stories
you know the the the character
narratives that could have been out of
those histories and things like that and
so uh i mean i'm really exci i'm still
really excited to see it i'm kind of
with you i mean yeah people's response
has made me go like i don't know man
like the lord of the rings fans i trust
them to be the experts but like this
looks so transportive and it does look
like it is building right on top of at
least the production values that peter
jackson established with his movies and
yeah just like all the environments all
the different races all the different
clashing factions and people like it all
looks really gripping and really well
assembled and again it i'm gonna be like
a broken record but for this show what
it keeps coming back to me is just like
please god i hope the writing is good
and i like the themes that are in here
you know they're universal themes and i
feel like in a trailer oftentimes for a
series especially you need to boil the
dialogue down to some of the major
themes of the show so i at least hope
that the show itself will not be so writ
large on the nose like believe in
yourself you can do it even if you're an
elf or a dwarf or whoever is being
oppressed by somebody else at the time
but yeah like this this
looks really epic and now it just has to
live up to the you know markers set by
both the lord of the rings movies and
now game of thrones is storytelling well
what i was going to say three minutes
ago john was that
galatrial
the part of it that strikes me as odd
because as cool as she looks as much as
she's gonna piss off all the right
people it's as cool as she looks part of
me was it goes i thought there was so
much more to her character than just
badass warrior and that's all this the
trailers have just been showing me like
i want to see a little bit more of you
know the the wisdom filled preachy
sorcery elf narrative of of galadriel
i'm getting just too much of a cliche
warrior right now while the performance
looks great sincerely i think it looks
like a great solid performance i thought
there was more to the character than
just badass warrior well yeah watching
these trailers i feel like i'm watching
like an aoen show uh the the you know
miranda auto character in the lord of
the rings movies you know brother of
aomere who you know rides into battle
and she's like the one woman riding into
battle uh you know it from uh you know
uh
oh i'm gonna mess up the kingdom but
anyway yeah
rohan there you go hey movie trivia
schmoedown champ that's right name and
all those fancy now look at me naming my
characters
oh you can't name the kingdom i know all
that other knowledge is just moved now
because i couldn't try it
i know rohan and i know gondor and i
know these other things and i just know
how to match the right one i don't think
you know it but yes it doesn't feel like
i'm watching that character's story
rather than galadriel which is fine
collateral doesn't have to have the
origin that looks like what i know her
from later but still yeah i agree like a
hint of it
a little bit yeah
some hint that that's where we will go
and that yeah you are some kind of very
special elven entity
um yeah but we gotta react to the
comments when galadriel pulled out her
lightsaber and said wakanda forever
set shivers up my spot token could have
never written anything better
nope true that bro
oh we got to go through more of these
from ava adams the scene where young
galadriel destroyed an entire imperial
fleet with her space horse by jumping
into them using a hyperdrive while
saying now this is podrick this is going
to make cinema history that's good for
eons people are going to study this
masterpiece of a scene just epic i wish
this this stuff would happen for reals
when dumbledore said you're a hair foot
harry he brought me to tears
such an amazing adaptation of j.r.r told
rowling yes yep yep yep joe rolling joe
tolkien oh god
all the comments are when legolas holds
up excalibur and shouts to the clone
army fear is the mind killer
[Music]
perfectly captured in such drama such
drama oh man when aslan commanded all
the autobots to roll out and kong beat
his chest just as the flying dutchman
erupted from the water with hagrid at
the wheel
goose bumps glad to see godzilla oppa
rexy ammo depp and general grievous
all my favorite classic characters from
lord of the rings oh man this is like
all the comments these are so funny when
sauron picked up the ring and said are
we some kind of lord of the rings the
rings of power brought chills down my
spine
incredible quote will smith is playing
sauron yeah then morpheus offered the
red and blue bill to collateral and said
you're a wizard harry i literally cried
because it's so impactful can't wait to
watch this wonderful adaptation of
george rr martin's lifelong hurricane
bravo
yep
i'm so rooting for the show
i wonder how the people at amazon must
be feeling it makes me if these are for
somebody but i'm also rooting for the
ship it would be nice to have everybody
pleasantly surprised the most expensive
show in television history has now
become one of the biggest underdogs i
love it isn't that that
should be i love it it's a big corporate
underdog
all right guys well what did you think
about lord of the rings the rings of
power official trailer are you happy
leave your thoughts down below you can
subscribe click that bell leave a like
last but not least let's do this with a
daniel gallacher you have a name that
reminds me of galadriel and you are just
as fair
and just as fiery and just as lovely and
passionate as the titul and well not the
titus not called galadriel but you know
as the main hero of this show and i
would follow you into battle at any
point any time especially because you're
in scotland there have been a lot of
battles in scotland so i figure you
would know what you're doing
and uh and yeah you can teach me a mere
man
how to realize my full potential daniel
gallacher so i hope you're doing well i
hope you're looking forward to this show
i hope you uh are satisfied by all the
different cameos from every fantasy
movie that are gonna definitely pop up
here
love you buddy and stay safe out there
stay safe